[Musique]
depuis des années le cas du footballeur
karim benzema suscite une vive polémique
dans le monde du sport
si pour certains son excellent niveau de
jeu devrait primer sur tout le reste
pour d'autres les polémiques à
répétition dont il fait l'objet sont des
raisons suffisantes pour l'écarter des
rangs de l'équipe de france benzema
n'est plus sélectionnable le principal
sujet liées à karim benzema est bien
entendu la sphère de la sextape de
mathieu valbuena
une affaire toujours en cours puisque le
parquet de versailles vient tout juste
de confirmer le renvoi de l'ex attaquant
des bleus devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour complicité de
tentative de chantage
une affaire embarrassante qui avait
conduit le jeune homme à être écarté de
l'équipe de france plus tard alors que
didier deschamps envisager son retour
plusieurs personnes dont le footballeur
eric cantona avait accusé des champs de
racisme envers benzema des mots très
difficiles qui ont conduit à plusieurs
dérapages dont un tag avec l'inscription
racistes sur la maison de l'entraîneur
c'est des moments très désagréable un
dérapage que didier deschamps n'a jamais
accepté et qui serait la cause de son
refus catégorique de faire venir karim
benzema chez les bleus alors karim
benzema est-il victime ou coupable car
c'est vrai que karim ben alaya moi je
reconnais j'aime beaucoup en voilà on
s'entend très bien avec karim benzema
elle c'est un mec qui a toujours été
hyper sympa avec qui on s'entend mais
pour moi c'est un immense joueur
mais c'est vrai que ya pas mal de gens
voilà qui disent qu'il ya un acharnement
autour de lui bernard montiel bout alors
ça ça date octobre 2015 c'était un match
amical l'équipe de france contre
l'arménie et benzema va voir valbuena il
dit
qui a acquis très sympa aussi j'ai très
sympathique
oui c'est en attendant la sortie un
camping hop il est important de le dire
et c'est très simple karim benzema
prévient valbuena comme quoi il aurait
intérêt plutôt à régler cette affaire il
était à balbronn a été harcelé depuis
quelques temps par des anonymes
évidemment au téléphone en lui disant on
nage en une sextape sur toi si tu payes
pas voilà est effectivement apparemment
quoi calmer diallo aurait alerté il
aurait alerté alors valbuena a dit que
c'était pas vraiment aidé à l'air
c'était une humble une injection si les
agences de gardiennage élections c'est
autre chose et les vaccins il a coupé le
sujet le sujet c'est du dojo et il se
trouve que ils ont ils ont mis sur
écoute de copain de karim benzema et que
sur par téléphone il aurait appelé un
ami de benzema mais tout ça c'est dans
deux injecteurs cette amie benzema
aurait dit vous inquiétez pas karim
benzema va s'en occuper directement et
va lui dire tu as donc forcément on sent
qu'il ya une implication parie-t-il
maintenant faire très attention c'est un
procès la justice suisse doit faire ses
préjugés mais là il va en
correctionnelle quand même c'est chaud
pour risque gros oui sophy cadets 1 mais
c'est surtout que en fait l'un des
maîtres chanteurs présumé en fait est un
et est un pote héros d'enfance se
retrouvent noyés j'ai plein de potes
quand on les conneries pas pour ça que
le risque est hallucinant mais ça fait
cinq ans que ça dure et c'est toute sa
carrière serre que c'était un type mais
sans moi qui faisais toujours un type
formidable
en football je l'adoré comme il n'y a
quand même été sélectionné par zidane
pour le real madrid c'est un des
meilleurs attaquants qui lui ont bien
sûr 80 et quelques chômage chronique son
histoire de sextape de chantage je sais
pas alors de mettre une carrière comme
ça enfin alors on entend les deux
m'appuierai l'ena et oui et karim
benzema liste